pues las manifestaciones huelgas y
bloqueos en este momento parecen
inevitables todos los sindicatos del
país sin excepción están de acuerdo en
rechazar en las calles el aumento de la
edad legal de jubilación de 62 a 64 o 65
años que prevé el actual gobierno Este
martes esas organizaciones ultiman los
detalles de su estrategia para presionar
al gobierno en la mira movimientos
sociales efectivos como el de los
chalecos amarillos que obligó al
presidente macron a aplazar las medidas
anunciadas en aquella ocasión Ese es el
objetivo esta vez porque la batalla en
la asamblea nacional no es clave para la
aprobación de este proyecto de ley
primero porque el partido oficialista
podría finalmente seducir a los
republicanos el partido de derecha para
que apoye el texto y obtener así los
votos necesarios y segundo porque si no
logra sumar a parlamentarios de otras
formaciones políticas podría una vez más
valerse del artículo 49-3 esa
herramienta constitucional que Elizabeth
ha usado a diestra y siniestra en los
meses para pasar leyes al senado sin
apoyo de la asamblea nacional la presión
social parece el último recurso de los
franceses para impedir la reforma del
sistema de pensiones y la pedagogía el
convencimiento la única táctica del
ejecutivo para evitar una parálisis del
país que frustrarían nuevamente la
implementación de uno de los pilares del
programa de gobierno del presidente Emma